this is what would happen if you had a  baby with someone in your family  believe it or not this is actually how  humans survived 75 000 years ago and  some royal families even do this sort of  thing gross I know but it can also be  incredibly dangerous and here's how  first cousins that have a child together  have an eight percent chance of that  child having some sort of health  problems like blood diseases or cystic  fibrosis and if you continued having  kids with other family members these  health issues could get worse and worse  could get so bad that your bloodline  could eventually go extinct okay I know  this is nasty but